étape 3 mai 2021 couvre-feu maintenu fin
de l'attestation en journée d ouverture
des collèges et lycées en 2011 levée des
restrictions pour les déplacements
interrégionaux ensuite étape 2 c on est
à l'étape de maintenant contre-feu
décalé à 21h il avait dit un mois y
avait laissé glisser une petite phrase
il avait dit on va égaler le couvre-feu
donc voilà ce sera à 21h dès le 19 mai
réouverture des commerces des commerces
et des terrasses table de six personnes
max ça fait plaisir à beaucoup de monde
ouverture des musées cinémas théâtres
salles de spectacles 800 d'intérieur
1000 à l'extérieur rouverture
établissements sportifs en plein air
étape 3 couvre-feu à 23h à partir du 9
juin
réouverture des cafés et restaurants
possibilité d'accueillir jusqu'à 5000
personnes au lieu de culture
établissements sportifs et ouverture des
salles de sport accueille des touristes
étrangers avec pas sanitaires et top4
fin du couvre-feu générale le 30 juin
fin des limites de jauge pour les
établissements recevant du public
possibilité d'accéder à tout événement
rassemblant plus de 1000 personnes
les discothèques restent fermés ça va
pas faire plaisir à roger le mec de
delphine inclus alors docteur ès qui ont
ce qui vous va vous ce calendrier
oui je crois que je trouve assez
réaliste et progressif la prise de
risque me paraît assez faible
l'épidémie régresse bien alors certes
mais des mauvaises graisses bien ou pas
vrai grèce puisque c'est trois fois plus
lentement que ce que nous avons observé
en mars avril 2020 d'accord mais ça
régresse et désormais même nous avons
passé le pic du nombre de patients admis
en réanimation à l'hôpital qui commence
à diminuer très lentement mais casse
gueule ça c'est ça c'est la question
principale on se dit est ce que hausser
de bons timings et ce qui fige et voilà
le timing ce qui nous donne là le
calendrier c'est la courbe est il là
vous me dites que la courbe elle est
plutôt on était sur un plateau là ça
commence à s'atténuer alors c'est
surtout ce qui est important c'est la
régression de l'incidence des nouveaux
cas de contamination d'accueil
malheureusement la situation en
réanimation reflète en fait aujourd'hui
ce qui s'est passé il ya trois semaines
ne reflète pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est d'ailleurs la baisse en
animation va se faire extrêmement
lentement par contre l'épidémie régresse
bien et donc effectivement on se
permette d'ouvrir progressivement mais
c'est vrai qu'il faut savoir qu'au 15
mais qu'elle adapte principal
malheureusement on ne sera pas aux cinq
mille nouveaux cas de contamination par
jour qui est le seuil qui permet
d'appliquer de façon très sera on sera
plus efficace la strate le dessus voilà
on sera 15000 très probable donc en
trois fois plus elle a un poids de 6
mais c'est là où il ya un espoir
important par rapport à une situation
d'avant c'est à dire à ce moment là
d'abord il fera plus chaud d'accord
qu'on va avoir tendance à sortir de chez
soi à vivre à l'extérieur ouvriers de la
fenêtre puis fabriqué christian c'est ça
le point important c'est la vaccination
va progresser et donc désormais très
probablement à partir à mon avis je
l'admets la vaccination s'ouvrir à la
totalité de la population est mis sur sa
le président il se dit bien sûr bien sûr
voilà c'est ça qui va nous permettre de
réussir le déconfinement